everyone loves to hate auntie series as
they essentially break all the rules on
YouTube there are business rather than
an individual creator and they simply
upload songs and clips from movies
adding nothing to them to make it their
own though it's easy to hate on them
t-series is actually an ingenious
licensing business and has effectively
taken advantage of the exponentially
growing platform of YouTube going to 142
million subscribers so with that many
subscribers how much money does t-series
actually make
well starting off with their revenue
their revenue is quite straightforward
as most if not all of their revenue is
from Google Adsense
they don't do sponsorships affiliate
marketing merchandise or patreon so all
we really have to do is estimate their
CPM or the revenue they get for every
thousand use nowadays as advertisers
YouTube as a much more influential and
reputable platform ad rates have
followed suit with some educational
channels saying well into $10 plus CPM
range however a few categories are more
or less stay the same or gaming
entertainment and of course music videos
this is because the audience who watches
these videos is much less likely to
convert into sales making them less
desirable for advertisers furthermore
when people get hooked to a song they
have a habit of looping it no this is
great for engagement and views this is
not so good for ad revenue as ads only
play once if you put a video on loop as
a result CPM for music videos are
generally in the 1 to 2 dollar range
something else to consider is that the
main demographic of t-series is in India
which generally has lower CPMs than
Western countries for instance the
median CPM in the u.s. is 5 dollars and
33 cents but the median CPM in India is
less than half of that at $2 into a
sense and that's before YouTube's 45%
cut so really the median CPM in the u.s.
is two dollars and 93 cents and the
median CPM India is one dollar and 11
cents
given this 2.6 four to one ratio and
estimating that the average CPM for
Western music is one dollar and fifty
cents this would mean that t-series gets
around fifty six cents per thousand
views to be conservative we'll just call
it 50 cents next up ask for the
viewership we all know about the remains
t-series channel which has been pulling
well until 3 billion range for two years
now but they actually have 29 different
channels with upwards of 200 million
subscribers ignoring the pandemic spike
t-series is able to pull in about 3
billion views a month with 142 million
subscribers so with 200 million
across all their channels they generate
about four point two to five billion
views per month or write about fifty
billion views per year with our $0.50
CPM this would generate twenty five
million dollars in annual revenue now
Bhushan Kumar the co-owner of t-series
has revealed that YouTube only accounts
for about 20% of the total revenue
meaning that the total company's revenue
is about 125 million dollars per year
but the other 80% of the company has
nothing to do with YouTube t-series has
been around since 1983 and they are a
legitimate movie and music production
company with over 45 films and that
continues to be their main revenue
source but for the purposes of this
video
we'll keep it to just a revenue from
YouTube which is a twenty five million
from Adsense now they don't get to keep
all of that though as I have to pay for
the licensing of the thousands of songs
they have uploaded and that's not cheap
by any means in fact half of their
revenue will go towards paying the
copyright owners there's not much
information available on the average of
price per view for licensed music as the
details for such deals were generally
not revealed but looking at the pricing
structure of one company that offers
music licensing for YouTube views for
non sponsored content they're looking
for about $115 per million views
however for sponsored content they
actually want 695 dollars per million
views t-series has a lot of bargaining
power with content owners as they can
expose their content to literally
hundreds and millions of people but one
main thing to keep in mind is that the
music t-series posts is not from small
to mid-sized companies that are still in
beta mode it's from some of the largest
production studios in the world so it's
no doubt that they'll charge much more
than a $115 per million views that lick
discharging plus the amount t-series per
million views is likely around 200 to
$300 estimating right in the middle
we'll call it two hundred and fifty
dollars per million views which wipes
out exactly half of the Adsense revenue
putting them at twelve point five
million dollars asked for their payroll
according to their LinkedIn page they
have three hundred and seventy two
employees
but it's likely that not many of these
people are actually involved in
YouTube's out of business as t-series
it's not a very labor-intensive channel
to run of course they'll need people to
negotiate terms with copper
owners people to post content people to
make thumbnails and update them and
they'll need accountants to calculate
revenue and payouts to copyright owners
but this can easily be done with ten
employees or less looking at a few of
the reporter glass store salaries it
seemed like they paid a tech workers
about seven hundred eighty dollars a
month let's just call it one thousand
accounting for any benefits or perks our
employees may receive with ten employees
this would cost $120,000 a year to
sustain we'll throw in another 30 K for
equipment internet office space and so
on and so forth
this means that t-series has an
operating profit of roughly eleven
million dollars per year after twenty
two percent taxes this leaves them with
a net profit of eight point five eight
million dollars annually now this is an
outstanding amount but comparatively
this is actually quite low for a
conglomeration of channels with two
hundred million subscribers there are
hundreds of youtubers with less than 10%
of the total sub-account who make about
the same or even more and they appeal in
comparison the companies have similar
subscriber counts so though t-series is
the largest YouTube channel by far
they're actually not the most profitable
channel if you're interested in learning
about the YouTube multi billionaire with
420 million subscribers then consider
check out my video on them and also
consider subscribing see more questions
logically answered but until then I'm
Hari and I'll see you guys on the next
one